françois roberge me sur berge bonsoir au
sol se voit alors on va aller avec les
questions que les parents se posent les
tests rapides parce que pour faciliter
la rentrée lundi est ce qu'il y aura
redistribution de tests rapides en
nombre suffisant pour que tous les
élèves en ramène à la maison
oui tous les élèves du réseau presque la
primaire vont recevoir au cours des deux
prochaines semaines plus de 6 millions
de tests rapides donc est aussi une
opération qu'on va répéter encore au
mois de février donc deux fois par de
zinc on va en voir équiper les familles
de ces tests là et pour les autres ce
posons des jeunes qui fréquentent les
écoles secondaires ben ali pour passer
par les centres de distribution que sont
les pharmacies je sais que dans les
dernières semaines ça a été difficile du
rebond vraiment que c'est par millions
comment recevoir vraiment dans les
prochains jours donc l'accès sera
facilité bon le protocole quand il ya
encore des cas dans une classe
quelle est-elle résumé moi qu'est ce
qu'on fait est ce que bon l'élève qui
est malade bien évidemment rentrer chez
lui ou ne va pas à l'école tout
simplement mais s'il a été dans la salle
de classe est-ce qu'on ferme la classe
ou on ne ferme plus la classe
donc un élève qui quitte des 70 doit
être testé au psy les symptômes se
développe en cours de journée
on peut faire un test rapide à l'école
mais on demande aux parents de tester
les enfants ils demandent en voit pas un
enfant symptomatique à l'école ça sent
le tester mais donc un enfant positif à
la coke doit être tirée pour cinq jours
et ça doit faire avant de revenir il
devra présenter un test montrant qu'il
est maintenant négatif et ça doit faire
24 heures qui n'est plus un bouton mais
le reste des personnes de la classe ne
sont pas retirés on ne ferme pas la
classe ok donc contrairement à ce qu'on
faisait avant les camarades autour de
lui au tour de son pupitre la
reviennent à l'école comme si de rien
n'était le lendemain
exactement puis les familles ayant reçu
des caisses et soit directement à
travers l'école ou même sens et en
procurer ailleurs pourront tester pour
être certains mais je vous dirais qu'il
n'ya pas deux protocoles qui dit on
ferme des classes où stocker des cas
présent
chds c'est un ajustement que fait la
santé publique évaluant que l'eau micro
est bien différent même d'octobre
aujourd'hui lors du point-presse direct
ici on l'appelle encore kobe donné au
micro est vraiment différent c'est chris
était même un nouveau cri russie et
c'est comme ça que la santé publique la
préalable à fonction des nouvelles
études donc dans quelles circonstances
on serait forcé de fermer une classe
écoutez sa soumission qui appartiendra
une direction de la santé de plus créé
gionale mais on n'a pas un protocole qui
dit voici l'heure quand tu arrives c2 c3
qui perd là on ferme des classes ce qui
est prévu ce sont pas des fermetures de
classes c'est tout simplement d'isoler
pour des périodes qui sont plus courtes
les personnes qui sont positives on
n'est pas dans des dans une démarche où
on ferme des classes on ferme des écoles
je suis brisé n'arrivera pas mais ce
n'est pas le seul la démarche très bien
juste une précision j'avais dit pour
qu'ils reviennent à l'école l'élève qui
a eu qu'a contracté la coved doit vous
avez dit doit présenter un test donc il
doit amener dans son sac ou le parent
doit aller avec lui avec un test négatif
ou le dire ça sera suffisant
je vérifierai mr ouai je vais pas
m'avancer c'est vrai que j'ai dit
présenter il devra avoir un test négatif
mais pour ce qui est la validation jeudi
avec le ministère et la santé sur le
détail parce que je crois qu'il n'a pas
à le présenter si j'ai lu la
documentation correctement mais avoir
hockey les masques les masques il y
avait des demandes depuis plusieurs
semaines les syndicats
docteur boileau aujourd'hui a dit que
les gardiens qui montrait
scientifiquement clé n 95 était meilleur
en car j'avais dû mieux respirer quand
vous l'avez entendu dire ça mais alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait si un prof veut
néanmoins un n95
n95 seront fournis et c'est une
nouveauté pour le personnel scolaire qui
oeuvrent dans des classes spécialisées
qui accueille les élèves qui ont un
handicap qui peuvent pas porter un
masque ou dans les écoles spécialisées
c'est une nouveauté c'est important de
le préciser seront distribués au cours
de la semaine prochaine très peu d'élus
dans les prochains jours
on pourra aller distribuer parce que des
fois on appelle ça des écoles hôpital
sont même des milieux de soins on les
avait pas on pourrait les avoir pour le
reste du personnel l'écouté de la santé
publique mais ma révisant ses études en
faisant un deuxième tour de roue comme
monty et en consultant la cnlc stay ne
ne recommande pas et ne distribuera pas
lié en 95 on considère que ce sont les
masses de procédure ce qu'on distribue
déjà qui songerait le bon équipement au
bon endroit donc si un enseignant veut
le porter il rend à acheter c'est ce que
vous
aimez ce club c'est parce que le
gouvernement va fournir parce que c'est
parce que recommandent les experts très
bien ventilation
ventilation combien de classes au québec
sont problématiques
selon le vote fameux votre fameuse
laisse que vous avez bien fait
on avait environ 10% de classe qui
avaient des taux supérieurs aussi
l'hiver dernier depuis ce temps on a
donné la directive au sein de
saint-nicolas de faire les travaux les
ajustements de ré parieurs de donner un
budget spécifique pour ça l'été dernier
on en a retenu notre l'automne dernier
et les travaux ont été faits donc c'est
environ 10% des classes et je veux dire
que ce nom
pour lundi
je pense pas qu'ils restent de classe à
la ventilation problématique mais dans
ces classes elle qui était préalablement
ciblés c'est là où on installe et les
premiers lecteurs co2 qu'on a reçues et
le réseau m'assure que ces locaux là
sont correctement équipés de lecteurs de
co2 donc lors de l'arrivée des élèves si
jamais on se rend compte finalement que
les change d'ère n'est pas suffisant
mais on aura tout de suite la mesure
puis contraintes des mesures
supplémentaires très très rapidement ok
vous ne vous êtes donc qu'il n'ya aucune
classe lundi
considéré comme étant problématique dans
votre liste
dans l'ensemble des classes du québec
c'est l'écho que je reçois des centres
de services scolaires mais sur ok on
peut aussi ouvrir les fenêtres parce que
c'est recommencer la partie bien sûr ça
fait partie des manières de philips
avait vanté les c'est pas brasser l'air
laventie laisser sortir l'air vicié
faire entrer de l'air frais puis j'ai
moi même enseigne et monta dans une
école que en fait dans le style
cotisations c'était l'ouverture des
fenêtres c'est ce qu'ont fait les mêmes
hiver je peux vous dire qu'ils avaient
la plupart du temps ce n'est pas en
trouver tout à l'heure à la récréation
pour et la classe et ça fonctionnait et
avec les lecteurs c'est au dos pour
valider et ajuster ses mécanismes de la
durée pour s'assurer effectivement que
le taux de co2 qui n'ôte indicateurs
nous t'aimons tu reviens y avait ce
changement quand j'étais petit avc bâton
pour nous vrai les fenêtres ont marre
des il y avait un élève par jour ouvrez
la fenêtre les peuples les parents
monsieur roberge vous avez là j'ai reçu
plein de courriels de gens qui m'ont dit
oui mais là on vient de faire l'école à
la maison vont quand même pas nous
demander d'aller en classe
quelle est la participation que vous
pourriez demander aux parents compte
tenu du manque de main d'oeuvre et des
enseignants et autres qui pourraient
tomber malade ouais j'ai vu ses articles
ses réactions là je suis je suis content
d'avoir l'occasion de rétablir les faits
et pas question de dire que maintenant
les parents
deviennent qui viennent enseigner en
classe ce qu'on le dit c'est que
le virus circule encore il faut
s'attendre à ce que dans les prochaines
semaines oui parfois un chauffeur
d'autobus ne soient pas présents parce
que hillion ne pas trouver un remplaçant
tout de suite si c'est un enseignant
bien sûr d'abord tourné dans la banque
du client la banque d'enseignants on
peut faire l'enseignement en ligne de
très près par une brève période on passe
à travers on peut assigner d'autres
personnels par exemple un conseiller
pédagogique qui a été longtemps
enseignant pourrait revenir prêter
main-forte temporairement et on s'y dit
ultime peut-être qu'on pourrait demander
des enseignants mais de fait que la
surveillance de groupes temporaire on
parle pas de dire que des entités les
parents pardon de vielles des
enseignants encore de venir faire de la
surveillance
de manière exceptionnelle et temporaire
ok c'est de la lecture même où qui très
bien monsieur le ministre on se
reparlera la prochaine fois parce que
c'est important de ne pas le temps
fallait qu'on règle les problèmes plus
technique
relié à la réouverture des écoles mais
de la réussite scolaire et de ce qu'on
va mettre comme bouchées doubles pour
les prochaines semaines une dernière
question en terminant y annonce dans
beaucoup de régions du québec le d'une
tempête de neige j'espère qu'on va être
pas trop frileux avant de fermer tout le
réseau
écoutez ça c'est genre de décisions qui
sont prises par des gens qui sont sur le
terrain
chaque sens de sa vie scolaire à
fonction des groupes en fonction de
est-ce que sont plus rural ou urbain
donc c'est une question de sécurité de
transport on vous souhaiter que nos
écoles soient ouvertes ont travaillé
fort pour les ouvrir mon école mais on
mettre personne en danger et monsieur en
fait sur terre merci monsieur robert je
la prochaine au revoir merci construire
et